this week on quadriga Mediterranean mass
grave is the EU to blame in the last 10
days alone hundreds of migrants died
trying to reach Europe from Africa
fleeing from war terror and economic
deprivation critics say the EU is guilty
of a criminal failure to provide
assistance and rescue to those in need
at sea the EU has responded with a plan
of action and promises more assistance
but does the block really want to help
refugees or does it only remain
determined to keep them out your host
this week Melinda crane hello and
welcome to quadriga this certainly is
not the first time that migrants have
died nearly within sight of European
shores and that that has produced a
public outcry so will this latest
tragedy really prompt fortress Europe to
look for workable solutions that's what
we want to talk about today on the
program with three people who have been
following matters here very intensively
Johannes light oiseau writes on german
politics and european and foreign
affairs for the front foot algemeiner
Saito Daniel gala is the founder and
editor-in-chief of Xena's it's a german
magazine focusing on politics economics
and culture in the Middle East and who
some Aldean is a Syrian journalist who
has been living in exile in Berlin since
late 2012 he was a documentary freelance
filmmaker in his own country who some
other in you also have been working with
refugees other refugees here in Berlin
tell us something about their stories
about how they got here and and what
they were leaving behind well I was
working we are like founder of a small
association it's called Salaam we are
helping with like refugees with their
problems and we get the stories of
course how they get here some of them
walking crossing the sea whatever I mean
why we have to go so far actually my my
parents my mother and my sister and my
I'm my brother also to they cross the
seals I was against that but we don't
have another solution I tried a lot with
the authority here to bring them like
legally but they refused as usual
because of the you know German law but
with my mom and my sister and my like my
brother it was very difficult for them
to live in Jordan and then they moved to
Lebanon from Lebanon to tokai tokai to
Algeria to Algeria Tunisia Tunisia Libya
Libya to Italy and from from Italy to
Germany it was a long long way and very
difficult to describe it it's very hard
and it's you said you said I came by
boat did they did they work with human
traffickers to to get the boat ride and
were they in danger of course the
Wellington Jeddah well somehow very
lucky because after five hours and a
half exactly the italian military they
saved up to be honest normally it's get
like a between 14 hours to 20 hours to
get like a tip like very close to see
silly old like lombardozzi oh and they
were quite lucky because of italian
military de around and they save them
but when i met my family in and italy i
I couldn't recognize them to win shock
their faces they have a big huge fear
they still like it they don't understand
what's going on that's their alive
because they were almost dying there
Daniel gala tell us a bit more about who
is on these boats and of course more
have been cut becoming since last
weekend's tragedy do many of them have
the kind of stories that we've just
heard who some Aldean describe well I
think there is a general prejudice about
refugees and about the nature of these
refugees and in Europe which is that
there's some kind of a very poor obscure
mass of people that are trying to invade
or our wealthy countries and that they
bring nothing
but a desire to live here this is not
true jobs and a desire for jobs well
these people out many of them are very
qualified I have met earlier like much
much earlier than this than the current
crisis emerged people from western
Africa I met them in Morocco who had
been shop owners who had been business
people and they had sold their
businesses and they had used all this
money for they gave it to the smugglers
to come to Europe I heard of the the
nephew of the former Algerian president
who died in in such a about about
accident in the Mediterranean and when
we look at the Syrian people of course
yeah it's I'm thank you for your
testimony because these are people your
relatives people we know and I think
this is we our our perspective is
changing now because we all of a sudden
see we come to know these people and we
we identify them and we we know more
about their stories and I think it makes
even though the situation is becoming
one more dramatic oui oui more and more
understand the individual reasons why
they come do we you had a slight wiser I
think they do partly I don't think we
are aware of stories like the one you
just told that people are just traveling
around the whole Mediterranean ending up
in Libya because there you have not only
able to control the borders and trying
their luck from from this country we
would think Syrians would try to flee
perhaps to Europe or to germany via
Turkey and then go on overland but not
not the sea I think we think Africa when
we think of these refugees still and the
meaning sub-saharan people coming from
Somalia maybe eritrea or other poor
country is Nigeria now trying to go to
go to get into Europe and in Germany
they maybe that's a bit of a special
case because we still have taking
refugees is connected to this question
of being prosecuted politically for
political reasons so that would
political analytical asylum would
include the Syrians but would exclude
people fleeing because they don't have
any possibility to around their
livelihood and the countries they are
coming from
Husam Aldean what's your sense of
whether people here not only in Germany
in Europe understand the background and
the story of the people who are coming
to their Shores well unfortunately like
this not much experience about that but
I mean I would like to mention that said
your opinion you know that's they're
talking a lot about the human rights
people they're mentioning that talking
about that but they don't really care
about the news there's a lot of people
they don't know where Syria they didn't
always Libya they don't have any
knowledge about those people for example
unfortunately so we are talking a lot in
the media but people they are not really
interested to know about it
unfortunately Daniel gairloch disagree I
really have to disagree here because we
can see if you look at our media um
until a few years until two years ago
let's say it we only saw like clips of
you know both disasters in the news for
a couple of seconds and that was it but
in 2013 you could really see a surge in
the media representation of the refugee
issue you would see more prime-time
stories about individual fates and about
individual stories and I really have to
say I don't want to praise our media too
much but I have to say that you know it
makes this the the front page stories
every time and not only if they are
disasters the entire you know weeks in
which television and newspapers report
about the issue so I don't agree that
that there is ignorance in Germany alone
i really i really have to ask ready
money about your whole Europe for
example UK France the Scandinavian
country not only Germany actually but
about Germany maybe they're more
focusing about this pain Italian or like
Lee's problem economics problem but not
so much about Middle East oh like Africa
in general and about Syrian situation
just like there's a lot of people they
don't know exactly what's happened with
the story it's a civil war it's a
revolution it's what kind of fight there
it's it like only it is there only like
rubbles or like
this a lot of people they don't have any
idea what's going on exactly johannes
light oyster even if the media are
telling the story certainly we're not
seeing EU immigration policy become more
empathetic if anything it seems to be
hardening after the lamb peduzzi tragedy
18 months ago many people will remember
that italy instituted a program called
marin ostrom on its own watch which was
basically a search and rescue a project
and i gather that your relatives boats
were intercepted by the italian navy
partly because of that program that was
around that time the fact is marin
ostrom has been terminated and replaced
by a new program called triton and it is
exclusively a policing and border
control program it is not search and
rescue exactly and the ships are now no
longer going towards the southern
mediterranean shores but keeping
themselves on the northern path so they
wouldn't spot many refugees in small
vessels not being able to make the
journey and might be drowning without
our knowledge even and that has chained
and this development came about because
the other european countries were not
willing to pay their part italy's said
at a certain point look we're doing this
now on behalf of the whole continent or
the whole Union but we can't afford to
pay for it alone all the time and that's
that's part of the problem we so many
times say Europe but Europe falls apart
if you take a closer look into countries
that are affected by certain problems
they have to deal with it and others are
taking a more laid-back positions they
look okay that's you're there you're
dealing with this but we have different
things to look after so this will now be
changed I'm sure after this tragedy that
recently occurred will it Daniel gala
and and should it we do have foreign
ministers meeting right now to talk
about the problem would reinstituting a
search and rescue program save lives of
people like the ones who perished last
weekend and
should search and rescue be at least the
beginning of a solution well it needs to
be revived and I think it's going to be
and if you look at the budget that is
needed it's it's it's ridiculous
compared to all the other endeavors that
Europe is doing in the in the
Mediterranean when we talk about you
know the banking sector and and the
umbrella for for greece and spain and
portugal whatsoever it's a ridiculous
amount of money that's needed here and
the Italians you know with all due
respect they've really tried to to use
the refugee issue also to keep a clout
on the European Union because I don't
want to use the term blackmail here but
but you know them it makes Italy more
important in the context of the 28
member states they were Greeks have have
been far more blunt in trying to use
refugees in recent days to achieve their
financial goals but they cut of you
mentioned they the you know the overland
route they cut off this overland route
and one of the reasons why we have this
disaster is because people cannot cross
over land anymore into the European
Union because there is a day they have
built a big fence in there patrolling
this fence so of course the European
Union has to has to react to this I
think is this is this is one step but
this is you know otherwise and not the
first one to mention this Europe could
be taken to an international court for
denial of assistance if they don't take
care of these people and I think the
foreign ministers have this in mind
speaking of denial of assistance who
some aldi in one of the things that
astonished me when I've read about some
of the cases of the past few years is
the private citizens who try to rescue
people in distress migrants in distress
can be prosecuted for aiding and
abetting human smuggling yes that's true
actually here but I would like to just
to mention something very important like
last year I made it like reportage about
lambda dozier issue it's very important
I would like to mention a long time ago
it's just remind people what that was it
was of course the foundering of about
350 over near our the Italian island of
La Medusa I metal pitaji with one girl
she's was 18 years old lost nine members
of her family
me half of them did I multi the other
half in and italy and the problem i was
asking many people who was in the same
boat and they told me we try to ask for
help the mountain government says no go
to Italy and Italians they go to Malta
so everybody trying to run away from
responsibilities and what I would like
to mention about it's that we are
talking a lot about human rights and
your opinion they're trying to help and
they like refugees but they are trying
to run away from but it like you know
their responsibilities that's very
important issue actually so disunity one
problem clearly that you raised johannes
light oza but let's look at the approach
as a whole because what we can see from
the 10-point plan that was introduced at
the beginning of this week indicates
that the EU is essentially bolstering
the same approach it's been using since
marin ostrom was ended which is an
approach that essentially ceased
migration as a problem of criminality
essentially criminalizing both human
traffickers and migrants under the new
ten-point plan migrants will now be
fingerprinted for example smugglers
boats are supposed to be destroyed
there's talk about trying to do border
control processing in other countries
say northern African countries is an
approach that essentially focuses on
criminality really the right approach um
I think you have to look at these things
because it has turned out to be a huge
business by now and even overtaking drug
smuggling and some extent so I think it
would be incomplete not to look at these
things but it can only be one part of a
larger action and the main thing is
apart from rescuing people risking their
lives or preventing them from risk their
lives is how do we deal with them not
only because they have already landed at
our shores but because we know they want
to come to our shores and we don't have
even a legal framework Europe
europe-wide what to do and I think this
has to be put in place immediately
because that's the precondition that we
could send some officers somewhere to
italy or sicily or maybe two to some
other countries maybe to Lebanon or
where else and say look that's your
issue we would accept you under these
conditions so we need a European asylum
but you know I have been hearing that
for probably 10 years now covering this
area 10 years that people have been
calling for a framework and then the
graph kind of looks like this there's
another tragedy and then the calls get
louder and then Daniela what has to
happen for it to really occur you know
the to tackle this issue with police or
law enforcement means is is is vain
because you we've tried this with with
with drug smugglers I mean you be honest
brought up the broad of the example if
there is a consumer market if there is a
demand there will never be a way to
prevent people from smuggling drugs and
selling them and it's only going to make
the business flourish so I can give you
a few examples what what I would I
personally written with witnessed in
Greece for example on the island of
Lesbos refugees arrived and the the
smugglers gave the the steering wheel to
one of the refugees and left so one of
the syrians in this case who came to the
shore was persecuted by the police as
the actual smuggler because he had been
he had been operating like technically
operating the boat we have seen other
spectacular examples dramatic examples
of big ships being hired and then they
put thousands of refugees on these ships
and they met they abandoned the boat and
the boat is floating towards towards the
coast of Italy of course you know one
person needs to be held accountable by
the police but nobody was basically
operating the ship so there's always
ways of circumventing you know
persecution you would think I mean if
people are operating this industry on
such a scale that that's organized crime
in a higher form and so I think that
there is an obligation to to try and
keep this down and follow the organizers
and the people behind it
well morally is it is it organized crime
morally I mean we're speaking in legal
terms yeah but to be honest is a person
I've discussed this with many smugglers
in Tunisia for example you know they
said we're doing something good we're
helping these people and if you look at
what's going on in Libya at the moment
you know I've just quote the example of
20 or ethiopian christians allegedly
being executed on the beach in libya
these African migrants that have
stranded in Libya they have to fear for
their lives they're not not only they
came for economic reasons but now all of
a sudden they are really their lives of
threatening and if somebody takes them
over to the European Shores is he really
committing a crime is disorganized
private I put that question directly to
who some Aldean whose parents obviously
or relatives obviously did deal with
traffickers would you say that the
assistance to migrants who want to cross
illegally is like smuggling is this war
on migration like a war on drugs or is
it something entirely different yes
those people there and my opinion there
Columbus and taking advantage of many
people for example each party and at
least in one day like a million dollars
minimum like when you get 700 people or
900 people in one board they get from
each one 1,000 1,500 euro each one so it
they're just like you it's waiting with
the people with a human being I mean
they put them in the risk if they die
they don't care Chile and yet without
them your family couldn't have made the
crossing well I was against it but
because my family they don't have
another option we don't have a daily
income and alway also the like in Jordan
they had a pretty difficult time Egypt
Adan the like welcome to like Syrians
turkey very difficult for the fugees
Lebanon it's quite impossible nobody
wants Syrians even so many they ask for
visa for Syrians so even if when they
want to alginate they want they have to
have everyone three thousand dollars in
black as a pocket money and now then you
need a visa to like you know
to enter visa sorry to enter Algeria so
it's quite impossible so they don't find
any solution like a good solution like
you have to risk with your life like
fifty percent if you survive you're safe
if you if you don't survive so you have
nothing to lose anymore so let me ask
you another point that Daniel Agger
laughs brought up how effective will any
of this be leaving aside the moral issue
of whether traffickers are essentially
providing a service that is in some way
humanitarian or whether in fact they are
simply exploiting a misery what about
the effectiveness let me just remind us
of some of the measures that are now
being taken by the EU destroying human
traffickers both stronger policing in
the Mediterranean tighter border
controls quicker deportation measures
for illegal immigrants and apparently
the likelihood of some border processing
in other countries where migrants the
Midway stations for them all of that's
being talked about would any of it
change the flow would any of it actually
decrease the attempt of refugees to come
well that's a big issue actually but
maybe I have the only suggestion that's
why only Europe they have to take these
responsibilities why not all around the
world they create the derrick and I'm
like America like in New Zealand
Australia or golf County even they can
help with that we only mentioned that
it's your opinion they have to take the
responsibility but that's not enough
even inside your there's a big conflict
for example in France they are not
taking the responsibility or like UK
also they are not taking this mostly
like Germany or like a Scandinavian or
Netherland they are taking some
responsibilities but why we don't make
it balance it's as you mention I want to
come back to that aspect the worldwide
refugee situation just a moment but you
mentioned Australia Australia is one of
the models that the current EU policy is
often compared to Australia adopted a
stop the boats policy a couple of years
ago and
many people say it has been effective
Johannes light oh is it has a number of
the elements we're talking about
including processing of would-be
migrants applications in other countries
in essentially a Pacific countries that
are could be countries of a transit is
that a good scheme is it working I don't
think it would work in Europe just for
geographical reasons I mean what the
Australis did was they shipped them off
the refugees they picked out of the sea
to small islands and in effectively
detaining them there and dealing with
their matters there that wouldn't work
in the Mediterranean on the southern
shores of Europe and we wouldn't be
ready I think to adopt this policy as
well let alone again I have to repeat
this there is no Europe acting like the
state Australia is acting so they would
have to be set many preconditions a
fortunately there's no because the
Australian example is dreadful is
shameful and if Europe ever accepted
like any any of that solution I think it
would be scandalous so in this as it is
a model that's being mentioned very
frequently now why why is it dreadful
and scandals well do you do you want
Europe to pay the neighbouring countries
in the southern Mediterranean just like
you know left aside the instability of
these countries pay them for detaining
the refugees because that's what's
happening in Australia yeah like that
with Qadhafi's Libya before exactly and
Gaddafi said he said it in one of his
last speeches if you think that you can
top on me then you will see what's going
to happen you know migrants will flood
Europe he he predicted them you know and
this was actually a way of blackmailing
the Europeans we have we have a moral
issue here and we have you know do do we
want to to behave like a rogue state do
we want to behave like the like
Australia of course we have like 28
governments that are constantly running
election campaigns but we should not
follow this example I've just remembered
we would like to remind you of this this
campaign you won't make Australia or you
won't make this country your home you
know this is this is this is shameful
and we should not you know even even out
of tactical or practical reasons ever
try to imitate
system and I mean there are different
things coming in from Australia at least
has a history of being a country
welcoming immigrants and you can see
what happened to to them now in in
Europe you have 28 different backgrounds
Germany for many many years claimed to
be not in country for economic
immigrants kind and Van Horn's lon other
countries have different have have been
colonial powers for instance like France
and Britain so they are used to to a
multicultural society in different ways
are not used to completely that's the
first precondition we have to bring
together and and draw a line said look
we have to find some common principles
about how many how we want to deal with
immigration what kind of people who want
to accept how about a moral obligations
and how far will we go and this is just
well in the beginnings let them to sorry
we have to be honest about the reasons
of asylum because we are forcing left
side the Syrians everybody understands
that there is a war going on and the
people are dying every day but many
other refugees are coming and we forced
them to lie we forced them to tell that
they seek political asylum because
because they are being persecuted in
their countries and they have to fear
for the life obviously this is not true
many many refugees are coming because
they have just one life and they want to
live a better life so they're making up
courses and we force them to make up
these courses because otherwise they
would be they would face a criminal
investigation or being said being sent
back to their country let's so let's be
honest about what reasons do people
travel that is taking a closer look at
some of those regions reasons you
mentioned the breakdown of Libya and
Qadhafi's threat Libya's disintegration
like that of much of the Middle East
does provide one reason for why this
problem has become so urgent let's take
a look although Libya is overwhelmed
officials occasionally make efforts to
stem the flood of refugees last week
they detained hundreds of migrants after
a series of raids but the scale of the
problem is much larger
that's okay that is such a fabulous we
fear that in the coming period if the
state does not intervene decisively and
effectively if the humanitarian
organizations and nations concerned with
combating illegal migration do not stand
together as one and provide us with the
necessary resources major humanitarian
crisis could occur many would say it
already is occurring for migrants from
poverty-stricken countries devastated by
war like Somalia and Eritrea the dangers
of the journey hold few fears I was a
student living and studying in Somalia
my country is at war and it's good for
nothing so I chose to travel to Europe
and may God bless me with good fortune
don't please move away what else we
don't what no I'm kidding bottom oh
we've left behind us is death death
death what what what there's no food
either ma please Ethiopia is no good
Europe is good please how open and
though some of them will be detained on
the North African Shore many more will
make it to Europe or die trying Husam
Aldean you mentioned it a bit earlier we
talked about this at the moment as if
it's a European problem but it is
absolutely a worldwide problem isn't it
people in the UN High Commissioner for
Refugees office are saying the entire
system by which we have tried to cope
with refugees since World War 2 is
breaking down yes that's too actually
there's a lot of countries like running
away from the you know this response
wouldn't like responsibilities like
United State they're talking a lot about
refugees how to support him how to help
them but look at the numbers how many
refugees they have Canadian 500l last I
second that France also they were
talking a lot about refugees and helping
especially Syrian people and la blah
blah but you cannot just check the
numbers it's just a few thousand not
more than that I mean compared to many
countries you know look at the Latin
American context when you talk about
America and we know many examples for
Syrians and other Iraq
these Middle Eastern refugees made it to
Mexico even like legally made it to
Mexico and then they illegally migrated
from Mexico to the United States and
they have been offered they've been deaf
and granted asylum you know they have
been accepted easily so i think you know
we should not only blame the united
states here they are of course I mean
make settlement they could like like
like a lackey refugees for example they
can make it like settlement like they
can people apply like legally actually
wide like a legal way I mean who can
like it the United State it's quite
impossible and you must be has a lot of
money and there is a very unloading Cleo
Mexico and it's high-risk maybe they
died with the smugglers there this yeah
I want to say there's a very unglued
thinking for a very global problem still
and it was recently mentioned in a you
know primetime talk show in here in
Germany that the refugees should somehow
stay in the region where the conflict
emergent you know what what's what's the
the responsibility of turkey or Lebanon
or Jordan in which way is it higher than
our responsibility to deal with the
Syrian conflict just because they happen
to be in the neighborhood remember that
in fact they have taken in hundreds of
thousands some of the millions of
refugees already you have this light or
what kind of numbers are we talking
about here let's say we could get some
sort of rational international approach
how many would have to be resettled in
order to defuse the pressure I think
it's impossible to say and you there are
the wilds of estimations on every scale
the German minister for the interior
just said there would be 1 million
people waiting on the southern shores of
the Mediterranean for a crossing how
many inhabitants has Syria and how many
are living in the refugee camps in
Jordan or Lebanon where they are at the
moment but that's not the durable
solution for them so even those that are
housed somewhere for the time being have
to be dealt with and I think I wanted to
adjust this idea of keeping them in the
region is I think the very naive hope
that the neighboring country
could deal with the underlying problems
and that's of course the thing we would
have to talk as well who's taking
responsibility responsibility for the
conflicts in the Middle East and who's
taking care of Africa the Americans are
no longer willing to do it to a large
extent so it will be left to Europe to
do this and I don't think we are
prepared to go into into a deeper policy
towards Africa kasama Aldean when you
look at the refugees you're working with
both within the association the project
that you're working with and also your
own family how many actually have the
intention the desire to remain here to
remain in Europe to most hope to go back
one day well I can tell you seventy
eighty percent would like to Kim would
like to come back because they go back
to their was you know they don't like
but like you feel like home here they
are forced to come here not because they
choose it all because it's my dream to
get to Europe or something like that
people really has a like a special
relation with their like nation with the
land with their country with the people
they would like to come back mostly
actually it's not their dream to get
here and to start again from zero and to
learn the language and to be with the
society it's quite very difficult for
them actually immigration experts of
course Daniel gala refer to that as
circularity the idea that you take in
refugees for some amount of time
immigrants for some amount of time and
then facilitate a return to their home
countries working with that concept does
that make it any easier to adopt a
liberalizing approach either within
Europe or internationally to refugee and
migration issues well it would probably
be easier to sell it by using this
concept concept to sell it to the public
but I don't think it's a sustained a
sustainable concept i think you know in
the 1960s and 70s we had a mass
migration across the Mediterranean
people bought at ferry boats and I think
a UN representative he recently said
quote
this example they bought at ferry boats
they didn't drown in the Mediterranean
of course the situation today is
different and the reasons why people
come are multiple but I think we have to
we have to be honest with ourselves and
say either we pay the price of letting
people drown at don't think that it's
going to stop even if we apply a you
know comprehensive approach people will
still die on the Mediterranean because
we cannot deal with all these individual
cases at a time we cannot put everybody
on a ferry boat and just like mass ship
them to Europe but there needs to be
some control but I think beyond that and
this might be even a taboo but I think
it's worth discussing it if everybody
wants to come to Europe because Europe
is the only safe place the wrong around
the Mediterranean then obviously there
is something with the concept of
citizenship and there's something wrong
with the concept of borders I think the
the fairest way would be to discuss that
Europe should take responsibility and
maybe also control of some parts on the
southern Mediterranean show you're sure
I think this is it sounds you know
people would come up and say well this
is neo-colonial why should Europeans all
of a sudden control the south of the
Mediterranean but if states fall apart
they need to be buffer zones and
honestly i think in libya a military
intervention is needed and you know I
know the Italians and the French are
ready for this and sooner or later they
have to create some kind of buffer zone
there where people could seek refuge and
tend not let the responsibility of camps
on the other side of the Mediterranean
as they did with Qaddafi and other
dictators and you know just like
basically have detention or
concentration camps in the desert of
Libya but control these protected
protected areas themselves Johanna slide
towards olivia is now falling apart
partly because europe did lead on the
air strikes in Libya but certainly there
was no leadership of any kind from
anyone in terms of reconstructing the
country afterwards didn't take part but
sunset to the elves we told you so
afterwards which was not very helpful
are we likely to see any political will
either in Europe or internationally
opted to to move forward with the kind
of scheme that Daniel agree with daniel
i see this necessity as well but i don't
think there's hardly any appetite to
take
responsibility for that we just had this
huge Afghanistan experience trying
nation-building with all kind of
idealistic imaginations first and we're
not very satisfied with the outcome the
politicians still claim it has been a
success but we're not so sure and I
don't think we would be more successful
in Libya because the region is so
unstable we would invite all kinds of
Islamist iktara wrists to to Libya if we
set foot on this ground because then
they had an example to show how they
blow up those bloody Westerners so it is
very very difficult but in it comes back
to the question who's taking
responsibility for Africa and and so we
where as if this goes on and on what we
experience now and we are still in this
moral dilemma that i mean there's even
this cynical notions the more fragile
the vessels are those traffickers said
the people in the more likely they are
to be rescued because when you're an
immediate distress every ship going by
has to help you these ships are looking
stable enough to make the journey
between italy and malta 10 times then
they have more likely to send from one
direction to the other all this so it
comes that comes with the price of
course this what I just suggested comes
with a very high price and with very
high risk but we have to be honest about
the alternatives we have either we do it
this way we do it that way or we'd leave
every leave everything as it is and we
will see more people drown and you know
some some people are ready to accept
this they say we have made our choice
and it comes with the price that every
now and then a couple of hundred people
will turn around in the Mediterranean
let's be honest this is what's going to
happen let me ask about another aspect
of political feasibility many people say
we will not see a liberalizing approach
to immigration that actually sets
realistic conditions for legal
immigration for people in political as
well as economic distress because of the
political situation in Western Europe at
the moment namely the rise of right-wing
anti-immigrant anti
EU parties who some Aldean have you felt
that kind of anti-immigrant sentiment
here as an exile in Berlin well kind of
ahead maybe because that I used to come
to Europe a lot and they was working
what did like a lucky refugees I face
these problems actually for also other
refugees for me not so much but a lot of
like refugees they had these problems
actually so do you think it's right
Johannes Latoya that that also is one
reason why we are seeing the EU
essentially stay with muddling through
containment and policing approach I mean
all these politicians look at their own
constituencies first and at their own
drops as well but there are many many
different elements forming this policy
for instance Germany at least it's
economically successful at the moment we
need workers for certain branches so
there's a counterbalance here the
economy is saying look you have to take
people in because we need them for the
jobs we are aging society as well we
can't reproduce the people we need to
keep up our economy so I think this all
forms the discussion here but you have
other countries like in Finland for
instance there has been a success of the
far-right party just at the moment and
again they all make up Europe and they
all take a part in forming European
policy and even here Daniel gala you
told us earlier well the media are
telling the story there is empathy there
and yet we've seen proposed residences
for Refugees burned down in a town in
eastern Germany we've seen massive
marches in dresden by people who say
they want to stop islamization also of
course through refugees from the Middle
East so even here in Germany with a
strong economy with the media trying to
tell the story doesn't seem like there's
a lot of willingness to take in legal
migrants well of course there is always
a couple of hundred thousand spoilers
there's always going to be a you know
a minority that you cannot approach that
you cannot talk to that is not
interested in the world but burning down
this remember example you mentioned when
a refugee home was burned before
actually actually the refugees could
move in this happened also before in
Germany this have happened in the 1990s
and the 2000s and there was not much
talking about it because it was not such
a big issue but it happened before of
course these problems exist but I don't
see that a major right-wing political
movement is going to benefit from this
issue and I also think that in a way you
know it's also pretext for politicians
to say well we cannot address this issue
to thoroughly because it's going to it's
going to you know encourage the
right-wing movements and right-wing
parties in our countries we see that the
success of right-wing movements in
Europe is not only you is not majorly
I'd say due to the you know immigration
policies there are other issues which
are much more prevalent and much more
important at the moment it's always one
issue and you know this this connection
between the the way between Islam the
topic of Islam and the so-called
islamization and refugees is just like
artificial you know it's not there just
for the reason that many of these
refugees are Muslims this has nothing to
do with Islam on islamization at all so
things people should not be perceived as
a threat they should be perceived also
as a potential but if they are join if
they're getting on these boats they will
they will become traumatized with these
experience they have it will be
traumatized and they will be much more
problem than if we just you know put
them on a ferry boat some alda in a
couple of years ago there was a film
that basically portrayed a massive
movement of millions of people coming
from the Middle East and northern Africa
many people say oh this is just a
horrible nightmare it's not true do you
think that's right is this just is this
the beginning of a huge time well I
think so will it start it soon
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us and thanks to all of
you for tuning in see you soon
you